[Music]
campaign season is just getting warmed
up but already we've seen plenty of the
usual stuff
candidates shaking hands hanging out at
diners and scaring voters about
foreigners who are taking your jobs
workers watch their jobs get shipped
overseas we are exporting jobs I will
fight to bring back good jobs sometimes
the threat comes from China Japan or
outsourcing to India that's why I oppose
NAFTA this time it's NAFTA the North
American Free Trade Agreement you know
all those Mexicans taking our jobs
everywhere you turn NAFTA is accused of
being a job killer 50,000 jobs this
country has lost a million more than a
million jobs as a result of NAFTA it's
true that since NAFTA went into effect
in 1994 some jobs have been lost but
many more 26 million more have been
created even with the economy that we
have today the unemployment rate is
lower than it was before NAFTA I oppose
NAFTA
early from the start and yet we're
always being lectured about the evils of
NAFTA have been devastated by
faith-based economic policies and how
our nation's bosses are selling us out
for cheap foreign labor looking to hire
cheap foreign labor over American
workers cheap foreign labor more cheap
labor
but if cheap labor is what we're worried
about there's a much bigger threat than
foreigners
politicians don't pay much attention to
it but Hollywood has been warning us
about humanity's inevitable war against
the machines machines and robots may not
be destroying us but they are destroying
our jobs now think about it how are we
supposed to compete against something
that doesn't get paid doesn't get health
insurance and never goes on breaks
everywhere you turn
machines are swiping our jobs think
parking lots need the human touch thank
you please come again this slot is fully
automated and robots have replaced
warm-blooded attendants please pay with
cash or credit card every time you go
online to book your travel or do your
taxes your nudging travel agents and
accountants closer to the unemployment
line you don't need a person to sell you
movie tickets do your banking or clean
your pool
sorry ticket sellers tellers and pool
guys oh and you two gardeners global
move a fully automatic lawn mower no job
is safe from the robot threat we already
have planes that fly without pilots and
symphonies with robot conductors
even the oldest profession may not be
safe we'll be getting freaky with thumb
box in just a few years say some
robotics experts how you surprised but
on the robot none of this is new the
soleus job Steelers have long waged war
against human workers two hundred
thousand manufacturing jobs have been
lost in this state manufacturing jobs
used to be much more common but did you
know that our nation is actually
manufacturing more stuff than ever
before how you guessed it machines are
doing more of the work machines are
replacing the people a machine is
standing there welding the parts
together pouring the material into the
forms stretching fabric over the seats
whatever it is dr. Adrian Moore says
machines have shaken up farming jobs
even more than manufacturing he should
know more grew up on a farm although
he's now an economist with the reason
foundation the nonprofit that produces
reason TV he still lives the country
life in Tehachapi California
there's no way humans can compete
against machines in a lot of the
back-breaking work in a farm for me to
go out with a hoe and hoe a small patch
of land a big garden say take me
probably days about 200 years ago more
than 90% of Americans worked on farms
yeah then came the machines a tractor
can do in minutes what it takes more
days to do Moore's daughter's sell eggs
to friends and the family still raises
some animals but farming does not pay
the bills today only about one percent
of Americans are farmers countless jobs
went to mechanical farmhands if you're
worried about cheap competition a worker
in China or Mexico might be working for
1/10 of what you're earning but a
machine is probably costing a hundredth
of that and it's getting cheaper all the
time of course you won't hear much about
this on the campaign trail I will have a
trade timeout trade time out how come
nobody wants a technology timeout big
corporations rushing to replace
well-paid American workers with cheap
foreign labor Lou Dobbs keeps a list of
naughty companies that ship jobs
overseas
why doesn't he keep a list of companies
that use job-stealing technology after
all the job he saves could be his own it
looks like technology is on track to
make you and I human news anchors
obsolete how come we harp on foreigners
but we don't rage against machines is
this Tea acre of the future actually we
used to in the early 19th century folks
called Luddites destroyed the textile
machines that took their jobs but before
you take a sledgehammer to a robot
consider some good news machines destroy
a lot of jobs in America but more jobs
are created travel agents may not have
welcomed the internet but websites
lowered the cost of travel and the
tourism industry expanded does this
explosion thanks to technology of
different kinds of jobs we were just
getting to know the Internet 10 years
ago today millions of Americans work in
Internet related fields they used to
make auto parts here it's easy to stand
in an empty Factory in Blaine NAFTA and
Mexico but free trade is a lot like
technology it lowers the price of things
for consumers expands markets for
businesses and provides jobs more than 5
million of us wake up in America and go
to work for overseas companies many of
today's jobs didn't even exist a
generation ago I live in a little
mountain town of 6500 people and I can
see these newly created jobs emerging
even here there are people here who are
in the pet sitting business there people
here that work for the private space
tourism industry and there's people that
work in the wind energy field but if
you're still not crazy about the new
economy there's always another option
buy a remote plot and live off the land
like our ancestors did just don't be
surprised that the simple life isn't all
that simple we all in this valley had
liftoff just what we can produce for
each other
one bad summer we get half the people
die and in a globalized economy when
things go bad in one country you can
trade with other countries for the
sustenance of life maybe someday we'll
realize that like technology trade gives
us more good stuff than bad till then
don't expect many politicians to say
nice things about free trade I haven't
changed my position I just wonder which
foreign nation Chelsea Clinton will be
thundering against when she runs for
president in 2024
Europa Oceana then again by that time
politicians might be replaced by robots
yes weak for reason TV I'm drew Carey
[Music]